today's video is sponsored by surfshark
hey jason hi
how you doing
i'm good i'm a little nervous
do you think you'll be able to get a
sense of who you have a connection with
without seeing them i honestly have no
idea because i've never been on a blind
date
so maybe but we don't know i have no
idea yeah
[Music]
first step go ahead a seat
[Music]
hi my name is dj well i love the name dj
first of all because of dj saved my life
[Laughter]
sorry man
i'm also into reading have you ever
really liked the harry potter series my
parents would not let me read them oh
really okay why does it sorcery
yo that's how it's super muslim i'm not
gonna lie haram
that's what the shape on
is arabic yeah
yeah yeah yeah they don't like magic i
don't like classics i don't know my
classics come on let me use so uh used
to let me watch uh lord of the rings
though really yeah yeah i used to go to
school and it was like man you read the
last harry potter book i'm like that's
just gay i don't read that [ __ ] but
really the truth is
you could watch it
you could have watched it you can't read
it
but [ __ ] dwarves and wizards hell
yeah that's fine let's get him gandalf
my mom don't know she thought this was
just swords and little people yeah yeah
i hate the gandalf
that's what it was what a little hobbit
yeah
big-ass feet don't even in front that's
how you see irish people
no
irish people is deep
[Applause]
that [ __ ] never gets off it never gets
old shout out daddy boy hey shout out
daddy boy that's never gets old
as soon as you hear ireland you think
it's potatoes
leprechauns
and [ __ ]
green i sing and i play the ukulele so i
can say i need you oh that's awesome
with that voice uh she probably won't
think you want to be her girlfriend
hey listen don't get me wrong i [ __ ]
with it all right personally i'm a big
daniel betting free plane
hang on batting field i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna get through this
i gotta get cause i gotta get through
this here's how i'm gonna get through
this
don't correct me on my [ __ ] when you
[ __ ] up i mark please okay
no no no daniel better feels a [ __ ]
classic he's unstable don't you dare
what's wrong with you because every time
you sing napoleon i gotta get through it
and it [ __ ] pisses me off yeah that's
right you gonna get through it yeah yeah
yeah
i gotta get through this i'm gonna get
through this
i just remember being a kid because that
[ __ ] would come up i didn't know
i didn't know anything about music but i
was like
and there's a bunch of people watching
right now who don't know this song but
there's a bunch of people who do
remember
when dino benefit was coming on you know
what someone was after what sonic
go fight
oh man
you gotta give me a melody because that
is not one i remember
you oh wait this [ __ ]
yeah i remember the phone hold up stop
stop stop stop i can't even up front
that [ __ ] was kind of fine
hey
[Music]
can you tell me a little bit about
yourself i'm a sex symbol
um
i'm a freshman at csu bakersfield i do a
lot of video editing i'm a youtuber
freelance model
screenwriter in some movies
i'm unemployed
hey man listen when somebody lists out
five occupations
generally for me i'm like all right bro
just because you [ __ ] got asked to do
a picture for somebody don't make you no
model
but
i'm a freelancer i'm a youtuber i'm a
model
and you're between all those jobs too
i think i have to cut ivan i didn't
think that he had like the confidence
and just like the outgoing character
that i'm really attracted to
guess who got cut first
daniel
your voice
can instantly turn off a woman
and it can also turn her on i know some
[ __ ] who got deep deep voices barry
white
that [ __ ] says anything but it's
not even it's not even it was not even
so much deep it felt like a hug
when this [ __ ] was talking it
was not just this it was a whole huh hey
baby
[Music]
there's just some things i want to know
there's just something that just felt so
grounded about that [ __ ] telling me how
you keep my own you keep i'm not gonna
lie man if you're if you're a woman
introduce you to a man she just met
and he got a deep voice
uh he deep in her walls
oh yeah
[Music]
what is your ideal first date i'm taking
you to a spot that i know um over by
where i live it's super romantic was
that was that the guy that was not able
to watch uh
harry potter yeah yeah you mean the
large muhammad dj
what was that what the [ __ ] oh no man he
looks boo so say that racist [ __ ] again
the lal yes say that muhammad
dj
for short because you know
you don't want to sound like one of them
in the states hey all the arabs watching
you guys can leave your angry comments
now eating is for sure hands down we
gotta eat i i'm not talking about salad
soup we gotta go get dirty i was three
steps ahead of you bro hey shout out to
these young guys they got no idea what
they doing but they talking and i
appreciate the effort hey man yeah we
not get no salad no meat but you don't
want some meat but we getting dirty
because you know chocolate all over your
face huh who what yay sauce video is
brought to you by surfsharkvpn a vpn is
an application or an extension that you
put on top of your browser in order to
change or to mask your ip address you
know to change the location of your
computer why would you want to do that
well sometimes i want to listen to other
content from other country and they
won't let me in knock knock who's there
canada won't let you in unless you're
from the uk
switch the vpn changer and then boom
knock knock who's there
it's actually the uk now
yes come in lord come have some fee i
know you guys don't speak like that but
you know what i mean so you're able to
watch much more content and then boom
the world is open to you just like
aladdin on a carpet i can show you the
world and for the next month you have 83
percent off and the three next month's
three if you use abba and preach code a
search vpn use the link below go ahead i
was just wondering if you could just
also talk about like your foster care
experience i've moved 34 times
but it's made me what i am today i'm
blessed for it i feel really bad because
i don't want them to think that it was
their fault at all but but it was your
fault based off what you said to me i'm
going to limit you
and there's nothing wrong with that like
no she's like i don't want them to think
it's their fault but it is because
because
the problem is not that it's their fault
or not
the problem is that she has to reject
them in their face yes yes she has to do
all that [ __ ] which you would have done
on social media i could understand i get
it i understand you know nobody wants to
be that dude like no no no cause he's
like oh this [ __ ] arrogant no she's
just sure what you want to say so
everybody got to do this whole like yeah
i mean
so okay i'm not interested i'm not
interested
my biggest deal breaker is someone who
is very full of themselves and is cocky
i would say my biggest deal breaker is
whether or not you can be we can be open
with one another i really like
connecting with someone on a deeper
level definitely people who don't like
respect themselves excessive like
self-centeredness in a relationship it
definitely takes two and people fail to
realize it's not 50 50. it's a hundred
and 100. and everyone deserves love
having someone that like really portrays
that and like embodies that like to
other people and like not to like just
like everybody no okay how do i say this
not like
to the people who deserve it like your
friends your family but to like
everybody to like the waiter you know to
like
okay first year yeah
the way they end the time
stop talking
and he says like yeah no no not
everybody not just your friends and
family but the waiter the dog the person
not out but your sister stop get some of
this time
and you
you know what i'm saying we're good we
gonna get dirty and you will get some of
this kindness
i like it though i like the energy
because he's going for it yeah but he's
bumbling and stumbling the whole way and
you gotta appreciate that i think
[Music]
she going for uh islam or uh
difficult power
foster foster care which one do you
think people tune into foster and he
said he does boxing come on bro
dj
no
foster care
yeah you have to learn boxing to beat up
his foster parents definitely graduate
with my bachelor's from pepperdine get
my master's in business management i can
also definitely settle down with someone
probably when i'm more established in my
career and
you know have a family and whatnot be
able to provide for them
with a beautiful wife so
oh that's so sweet
oh we're getting real right now
oh goodness what are your goals in the
near future and just in general in life
right now i'm
very close to finalizing oh opening up
my own gym and how did you know you
wanted to get into coaching again
because i knew a good coach when i saw
one and that's exactly what i wanted to
do is pay it forward
awesome
but when i set these goals it's not only
for motivating myself but it's also
motivating the people around me just to
kind of be the best person they can be i
definitely want to try boxing one time
i've never done it any time you would be
willing to um i'll i'll invest some time
into yeah this motherfucker's a winner
punch your hole with this dick
what did you say put your hole in this
dick
did you say punch your hole in this dick
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you i can
punch you all with this dick no you say
i'll punch a hole in this dick roll it
back punch your hole with his dick punch
your hold of this
dick
but it's wrong no no your sugary ass
hurt what you want
you know what the audience won't be the
final verdict editor you wrote that [ __ ]
back and let us know which one [ __ ] up
puncher hold this dick because it wasn't
me
i didn't say that [ __ ]
what
why you say [ __ ] like that bro what's
wrong and who punches a hole in dicks
boxers i guess
i think i know who i want to choose
first let's weigh the pros for
i really like that he was able to open
up to me i don't think a lot of guys um
are able to do that and now that you've
opened up to me i'm gonna choose the
other guy
because i don't want you to open up all
the time i find it disgusting
i appreciate it i'm not mad at her
though i think i will choose cody
[Music]
i do can i see her
that's my dude let me see what happened
y'all cannot see her now yeah cause we
punching holes in something
i really loved your background and how
dynamic and different it was from the
other guys
i loved how it kind of gave you a sense
of maturity i'm flattered like beyond
flattered it's taken me back that you
took so much from so little of
conversation before i see you um and you
see me
can we set something up like dinner or a
hike or coffee uh yeah sure i'd love to
all right cool because i want to make
sure i mean you know i'm gonna show you
everything you know what i mean because
we're gonna set it up right now before
you know you say no
i'll call you back here's a reveal let's
see if it gets awkward
[Music]
hi i'm jason nice to meet you
pleasure yeah okay
you guys now that you see each other is
it you look the way that you expected
the other person uh i had no idea
i had no idea it was you at all i i
don't know
just look at the body language uh did he
look like what he would look like i
don't know i had no idea i had no idea i
had no idea
this
this body language is not like i find
you sexy which hey
now that you've seen cody do you still
feel like you want to go on a date with
him um
i i feel like i would try it out just
see what happens maybe
bro okay
this right here um
this
this is
um
okay
um man feel bad for cody because you did
good too yeah you did good but
yo
that's a hell yeah on my part
i i'm just saying i gotta hide my
enthusiasm but
[Music]
i didn't
expect him to look the way that i
thought he would look but yeah he seemed
really nice does he look like you're
type
no he definitely was not my type but um
um
he uh he seems really nice that's not
the question you mean no
not necessarily i mean i'm confident in
being comfortable i guess you can say
just like
being me but um
confident in somebody picking you
not per se
i'm
more more than willing to more than
wanting to
um this is dope
[Music]
so wait till you see the edit
yeah
because that's how the editors were
laughing when they were editing oh yeah
let me say this there's some good
there's some good material right
sometimes ladies you guys got to learn
tactics sometimes cruelty
and an effort to try to be nice you guys
draw out the truth and you stretch it so
far we can't tell what it is you're
trying to say
where you could just save everybody a
lot of trouble and a lot of heartache by
just saying no
you know just sometimes i'm not saying
it's always got to be the case because
sometimes it's not safe for y'all i get
it i get it but sometimes it is and
sometimes you just want to avoid these
situations like say i'm not interested
you know especially with somebody you're
not even like attached to a relationship
with us just like you just met
it's okay to just sometimes say no and
it's not gonna bruise everybody's ego
it's gonna make a lot easier for
everybody so just wanna know sometimes
kindness is not actual kindness so
that's just something to say but
yeah i mean he thought he won and he won
and then he lost so
that's the thing that's pretty much it
what do you think about the whole ending
yeah
she was not into him
but to be fair to be fair
i don't think none of the guys were
her thing
i think she
actually
she would have maybe go for dj
physically
that's the only dude that she would be
like oh yum maybe i think but the other
guy was like no i don't think it was
happening
they did it dirty hey man cody keep your
head up i'm sure you're doing fine
though stay in there
fox out